but there's actually a much an even
bigger problem
right but wait it gets worse okay
not only can z to the n be uh
multi-valued
zen to the n can actually take on
infinite values
if you choose a an appropriate or you
might like to think of it as an
inappropriate value
for n if you raise not just to a
non-integer power
but if you raise to a complex power
something with like imaginary components
not only can z to the end be
multi-valued
it can actually have infinite values not
just like
2 like we have here i can actually
generate
any value that i like if i'm raising to
a complex power you might say that
that is bizarre that is weird well let
me explain to you by way of an example
how this works let's just consider this
z to the n which we're saying
is multi-valued let's consider it for
something really pedestrian
like z equals one which is kind of
analogous to what i was doing before
here right like a theta value of zero or
a theta value of two pi
on the unit circle that's z equals one
right so we're going to choose
z equals one and then we're going to
think about well what happens if we
raise that to the power
of i what is 1 to the power of i
now you may have an instinct in your
mind from what you've learned in
in the real number world already right
one of the sort of fundamental things
in uh index laws is if you take 1
to the power of anything like 1 squared
or 1 to the power of 20 or 1 to the
power of even the fractions that we
looked at before
we would have said all of those are
equal to 1.
a really fancy way of saying that is
that 1 to the power of x
will always equal 1 for all
uh values of x that are real put in
1 to the power of a real number and
you'll get 1 at the end so your instinct
might be
that one to the power of i is one it's
not a bad instinct but let me show you
why
it is not nearly sufficient follow with
me
okay what we're going to do first is
we're going to consider
this value there let's consider in polar
form so if i
write z in polar form
like i saw earlier this is a modulus of
one
and it's going to be an argument of well
let's let's take the principal argument
just to start with um that's going to be
1 being equal to cos of 0 plus
i sine of 0. so this is kind of like
your stock standard way to write 1
with the trigonometric sort of terms to
give you the the
real component and the imaginary
component so far so good but
kind of like i sort of alluded to i've
just taken the principal argument this
is not the only way
to write one as a complex number as a
number on the complex plane
and because of the periodicity of cos
and sine like they repeat every two pi
radians
i can write one in an infinite number of
other ways just by
adding or subtracting multiples integer
multiples
of two pi so just to look like one
one multiple of two pi on either side
i can say well it's also um
you know oopsie daisy additionally or
also
one equals uh well i'm going to write
dot dot dot because there is an infinite
number of these but let's go one to the
left and one to the right okay
so i can write it as cos of negative 2
pi
plus i sine of negative 2 pi of course i
could do more of these but
this will be enough for us to
demonstrate the point that's 1 to the
left let's go on to the right so that
will be cos
of 2 pi plus i sine
of 2 pi and again that sort of goes off
forever
now in order to work out well what does
this mean in terms of
exponentiation raising to the power of i
i've got to get back into exponential
form to deal with that at least to know
how i should evaluate it so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to say 1
equals and now like i have on on the
page right now i've got uh one
two three different ways to write one in
polar form
so that gives me dot dot dot three
different ways to write one
in exponential form it's e to the i
negative two pi it's also e
to the i 0 and it's e to the i
to pi positively and of course that goes
on
now that i've written this in
exponential form i'm ready to start
thinking about what happens when i raise
everything
to the power of i 1 to the power of i
is going to be equal to well let's just
think about this right
just like i did on our almost a very
first line of working right
if i raise something to the power it's
the same as multiplying
by that power right so therefore i'm
going to get here
this term here when i raise it to the
power of i it's going to be i
times negative 2 pi times i so in other
words it'll be there'll be an
i squared there right so let's see here
i'm going to get i squared which is
minus 1 and then there's a negative 2 pi
hanging out there here you're going to
get i squared out the front
again which gives you negative 0 which
is still 0.
and then here you're going to get i
squared times 2 pi so that's
negative 2 pi dot dot dot
so what we can see here is that in fact
1 to the power of i
has these distinct values let's deal
with the um the negatives here where i
can
so this double negative is just going to
cancel gives me e to the 2 pi
e to the negative 0 is in this context
still zero
and then you've got e to the negative 2
pi uh sorry yeah that's right
dot dot and it keeps on going right so
from here what i have on the right hand
side
all of these are just real numbers um
they're weird real numbers like i've got
this all this transcendental business
happening over here
but i can evaluate these right um i can
say well
what is e to the neat to um e to the two
pi i should say that's let's just take
the positive one right
so i've already got some um i've got my
calculator over here let's go
i'm actually going to use this a couple
of times a few times so i'm gonna go
e to the power of let's raise that power
and i'm the first one that i'm
interested in doing is 2 pi
so 2 and then pi
wow that is a big number right so i'm
going to write
e to the 2 pi that's 530
uh that'll do i think that's enough
decimal places there okay
so that's e to the two pi crazy um
then i've got e to the power of zero i
actually don't need my calculator for
that
that's just 1. and then i've got e to
the power of negative
2 pi so let's raise that to the power of
negative 2 pi and i'm getting
let's see here 0.001867
dot dot dot uh
wow bananas okay so what what am i what
can i say
from all of this right well what i've
got here is
different values different real numbers
that all are purporting to be equal to 1
to the power of i and
these are not the only ones right not
only can i go off in
further integer values i can actually
say wait a second
this can take on any any different value
that i want
if i take on like 1 to the power of not
just i but 1 to the power of some other
you know multiple of i or something like
that will lead to
some other value of you know not just uh
an integer multiple of two pi
i could have um one to the power of half
i would be just e to the power of pi
one to the power of a quarter i would e
e to the power of pi
on two and on and on so in fact i can
actually
let's uh introduce here a power
and just put in a slider there i can
actually
make 1 to the power of some imaginary
number
some imaginary multiple of i as you can
see it will vary the value of e
to the power of um you know 2 pi
times that whatever multiple i that i
chose so i can literally make 1 to the
power of
z i can make it equal anything so this
is not just
multiple values it's infinite values
this is a problem right we were trying
to say right at the beginning that
tomorrow's theorem
gives us this nice neat relationship
here right raised to the power of n
equals this but we've seen with
non-integer values
especially with complex values you run
into some serious
problems so take your breath for a
moment what can we conclude
and before we move on demonstrate
theorem
only works for is only valid for
um integer values of m um so therefore
in fact our proof
for demarcus theorem using the
exponential form while valid it has to
come with these caveats we have to say
yeah cool it's true but watch out for
the domain
of m